From the Library of Congress and the Smithsonian National Museum of African American History and Culture.
We're rolling.
Today is Monday June 6, 2011.
My name is Joe Mosnier of the Southern Oral History Program at the University of North Carolina at Chapel Hill.
I'm with the videographer John Bishop.
We are in Atlanta, Georgia at Cascade United Methodist Church to complete an oral history interview for the Civil Rights History Project,
which is a joint undertaking of the Library of Congress and the Smithsonian's National Museum of African American History and Culture.
We are especially privileged and very pleased today to be with Reverend Joseph Lowery.
Reverend Lowery, thank you so much for sitting down with us.
You're quite welcome. You're going to be able to be on the mail.
I thought I might advise, as we're going to be talking here today mostly about the 50s and 60s,
and then a little bit, a few questions there after, mostly 50s and 60s.
And I thought I would take you back to Warren Street Methodist Church and have you talk a little bit about Mobile, Alabama,
and Alabama more generally in the 50s and what you encountered there and how you began to lead your congregation and participate in efforts to change the...
Well, I went to Mobile, Alabama, to Warren Street Church in 1952.
And the NAACP was holding its regular meetings in Warren Street, so I just jumped right in with them because we had not organized SCLC at the time.
SCLC came in to be in the latter part of the 50s following the Montgomery Boycott, but the NAACP was active.
And as I said, they met in Warren Street Church usually on Sunday afternoon.
And so I had already been active in the NAACP in earlier years, and so it was just a natural for me to join with them.
And we engaged in voter registration and in educational activities designed to help African Americans understand our predicament,
and how it was incumbent upon us to find a way out.
And it was an interesting journey.
The NAACP was headed by a man named John LeFlore, who was active in Mobile, and until my arrival I don't guess John had any opposition, not opposition, but competition for activism in the city.
He and I became friends, and then later the friend-lept friendship experienced a meltdown, as we sort of went on separate ways in terms of activism.
John was a typical NAACP and a great person, but his forte and his probably the maximus of his activism was filing suits and writing up complaints and protests against what happened.
But Mobile was an interesting town. It was racist, but not the same toxic racism that you found in Birmingham and Montgomery.
And so that even during later years when the movement became prominent and active, you didn't read as much about Mobile as you did Montgomery in Birmingham, because Mobile was, in many instances, a quietly affecting change, and they had to be an occasional explosion of activism to keep them honest.
But Mobile had some interesting leadership. God named Joe Langan, who was a Roman Catholic, was a city commissioner.
And he was a man with a warm heart, and did not have the cold and icy stare of the heart toward the black community.
And so in many instances we were able to achieve change without the disruption of the community that we had to have later to achieve even more drastic change.
But Mobile was sort of like a little New Orleans. It's a matter of fact that people in Mobile claim that the Mardi Gras was initiated in Mobile, or not New Orleans.
I never bothered to research that side where it comes out. But Mobile, the Roman Catholic influence did not lend itself to activism in terms of change, social change.
So that resolution and law suits and that sort of thing, the main focus of the civil rights movement, and as the years progress, activism progressed and we moved away from just resolutions and statements and so forth to activism.
To sit-ins and march-ins and other things. And when we, when the Montgomery Improvement Association, when the boycott started, I was president of the Interdenominational Ministerial Alliance.
And we carried the first $1,000 I think, which a lot of money at that time, from a church's immobile to the Montgomery Improvement Association.
And I spoke to the mass meeting and that even now as we had a paper sack full of money, the crowd went wild because that was the first outside support they had received for the boycott and they were very happy about that.
And the later we initiated our own bus movement in Mobile, which went off much smoother than it did in Birmingham. And again, I credit Joe Langan, his leadership, which I said in the commission for the attitude that existed.
And we, the ministers decided that since I was president of the Ministry of Alliance, I ought to ride the Prichard route, which was perceived to be the most dangerous volatile route.
And we had a couple KKK had considerable routes in Prichard. And so we chose one day to ride. We had head workshops. We had people down from fellowship of reconciliation to lead workshops on how to conduct nonviolent demonstrations.
And so we met that morning and everybody cleansed them, said, purged themselves of weapons, and had prayer. And we took out on the bus route, sitting in the front of the bus and Reverend S. M. McCree, who was passed by my side in Baptist Church in Mobile, was my partner.
And we rode on the front first, the first seat that faced the front on the bus, going to Prichard. I think it was number five. And not long before we got started, I felt like I got on the bus with a sack in his hand, with obviously a bottle in his sack.
And he sat down on the little side seat right behind the driver. And at first he didn't notice us. But as he experienced the sobering ride to Prichard, he recognized that he were two black people sitting on the front, pew off of seat.
And so he told the bus driver to make us move. And the bus driver was all, you just ride, leave the driving to me. And he said, by God, if you don't make a move, I'll make a move. And so he stood up.
And there was our first opportunity to put into practice the nonviolent tactics that we had learned in the workshop and the bus driver in the mean time was pulling the bus over. He was going to intervene, I think.
And I remember Cree, Puts you with his arm, looked like he put his hand in his pocket, I said, oh, oh. And anyway, the fellow kept coming. I said, sir, please be serious. It's dangerous to stand up while the bus is moving.
I know you don't want to get hurt. We don't want to see you get hurt. you mean us no harm and we mean you no harm, you know, please sit down. And everybody held the breath, not knowing what every act would be. And believe it not, he said, we were the most of those two black preachers, probably the most surprised people on the bus.
And in two more stops, he got up and got off the bus, slam the door. He was very angry. He said something back to the bus driver. I don't remember what he said. Then we went on, rolled on to the prison to the end of the line. And then we're some black people in the front. We got off.
We mentioned to one of the ladies, she said, y'all, say we're getting the buses. You know, we're, we're say we're getting the buses. I said, aren't you tired of having to ride in the back? She said, yeah, I guess so. She said, but I've been back there so long. I'm not sure how I feel right now, but I'm glad you're all doing it. We said, thank you. And so we caught another bus going back a town. That was the end of the experience that was sharing in Mobile.
But Mobile, as I said, was racist, but the racism wasn't as toxic. Let me take our conversation towards one month.
All right.
Okay, we're back after a quick pause. Let me have you describe if you would those very busy and tumultuous months through 50 late 55 to 56 in the boycott.
And how that context would get rise to SCLC and in part originally, I think because the Alabama state officials, of course, had come down so hard on the NAACP that there was a place now for the group of ministers, pastors to begin organizing.
Well, of course, the Montgomery Improvement Association was organized to handle the boycott.
The NAACP was outlawed in Alabama and Governor (John) Patterson saw to it that he demanded the role, the membership roll.
And of course, the NAACP refused to give it because that meant they were going to harass the members.
And so they held the NAACP in contempt and eventually with the court. But the people refused to give up the membership roles.
And the Montgomery Improvement Association was organized. Dr. King, Dr. Abernathy, were the leaders.
And Dr. King's leadership was pivotal in the effectiveness of the boycott.
And that even when they bombed his house, he challenged the crowd to go home and not return an eye for an eye, or a tooth for a tooth.
And that we were on the right side and that we'd win because we were on God's side.
And that movement of course spread to other places, to tell us about the ruins and other places.
And that led us to the experience that I mentioned earlier, our writing on the bus.
That was after the Montgomery people had begun their initiative.
And the conversation among leaders of the movement in Tallahassee and Birmingham with Fred Shuttlesworth Tallahassee with C.K. Steele in Tallahassee with Kelly Miller Smith in Nashville with T.J. Jemison.
All of us would come together to meet in Atlanta.
And we decided that we were going to organize a South-wide movement to strengthen each other, support each other and to have a national impact.
And while we were meeting in Atlanta, they bum Ralph Abernathy's church.
And we adjourned the meeting and reconvened later in New Orleans.
And so the official birthplace of SCLC was New Orleans.
And only because we interrupted the meeting in Atlanta so that Ralph could go home and see about his church at home and family.
And of course the great turmoil ensued in Montgomery and Birmingham, Fred Shuttlesworth, the leading in Birmingham and Martin and Ralph in Montgomery.
And a big mass meeting one night in Montgomery and we drove up and we got there.
The clan had already seized the town as it were.
And we ended up not being able to get to the church.
The clan was going to the hotel and old Ben Moore Hotel.
And while we were hiding, I guess as it were in the hotel, we were cut off from the church.
And Martin called Attorney General and they dispatched law enforcement to the church and disaster was avoided.
But that was the beginning of SCLC who we decided that we'd have a South-wide organization and we could strengthen each other and spread the movement across the nation.
And Dr. King was elected president and I was one of the vice president.
Well I think I was elected secretary at first and lead a vice president.
But that was the beginning of SCLC.
A couple more questions about that period when SCLC is coming into being.
Did you have much contact with Bayard Rustin?
And Byron came down to Montgomery several times and met with us in pulling together the written DCs that formed the bases for SCLC.
And he was very helpful in that and he was a brilliant man.
And we welcomed his assistance.
And he didn't charge us anything which was good because we didn't have anything.
No charge, no debt.
But Bayard Rustin, yes he came down several times and worked with us for a long time.
Later they developed some differences in the movement.
But Byron was a very influential figure in pulling together the people who worked particularly for the early days of SCLC.
Let me ask if you would just reflect a little bit on Young River Dr. King's emergence through those several years.
Well Dr. King of course emerged in Montgomery leading that boycott.
It was the first time that a city with 50,000 black people had successfully and effectively implemented a boycott.
Their houses were bombed, threats came but Dr. King stuck to the nonviolent motif and led the people to accept nonviolence.
Many of them accepted nonviolence because they had confidence in leadership.
Not because they were convinced that nonviolence was necessary the best way because I remember in Mobile some of the ministers that worked with me used to tell me for a blank.
I'm not going on this much with you because I'm not sure I can be nonviolence.
You can't be nonviolence because you would bring harm to the movement if you resort to violence.
We have to take clean hands.
Of course Martin's leadership was recognized.
Montgomery boycott for over a year was effective.
The first time in our history we were able to sustain that kind of boycott for that long period of time.
He was heralded across the nation and then across the world as a nonviolent leader and of course his eloquence as a speaker.
His personality as a minister and a pastor was extremely effective.
He became the natural leader when we organized SCLC.
He was the first person who came to mind as president and went on to give the kind of leadership that justified our confidence in him.
In those early first few years late 50s for SCLC much of the day-to-day work through the late 50s was carried by Miss Ella Baker.
Ella was I guess the first real executive director full time executive director that we had.
We had a fellow named (Rev.) John L. Tilley who came out of Baltimore who had done an effective voter registration trial.
But he didn't last long and Ella Baker became the full time executive director.
I think history may have overlooked she was the first woman to give that kind of executive leadership to the civil rights movement and she was very effective.
She didn't get along very well with the preachers.
I'm trying to remember what was at the bottom of that and I don't remember what she was a strong woman.
And that may have been one or two.
Maybe preachers who had some problems with strong women like some of you felt that may still in this time have problems with strong women.
But she did a good job. She was an effective man.
And I heard leadership and inspiration students were inspired and organized SNCC.
And they became this young wing of the nonviolent civil rights movement.
Let me ask them. We're going to turn to that history from 1964 and just a minute.
But I want to ask one last question about two questions. Maybe about this critical period.
One is in your own thinking is it evolved through the 50s.
What was your perspective on? You've already touched on this but can you say a little bit more about the theory of nonviolence and how it connected to your Christianity and to your both tactical and theological perspectives about the movement?
Well, you're right. It had a practical aspect and it had a theological aspect.
From the practical perspective, we looked at our army and we weren't very...
We weren't many of us. We had never any weapons. We didn't have any uniforms.
And we looked at the National Guard and the state troopers and the deputy sheriffs and police city and city.
And we were outmaned. So for a very practical perspective, we could not have won a violent confrontation.
It would have been catastrophic for us. And it's also interesting that the white organizations, the group of clan, others, they didn't know how to deal with nonviolence.
They were frustrated because the more they were violent against nonviolence people, the more they were criticized.
And the more the world saw them for what they were and began to sympathize and support.
And even those who may not have first supported sit-ins and direct action were disgusted with the violence and it turned the tide.
The other side of theological side was very... because if you notice, leadership in the movement was almost always preaches and in its searches.
And there were two reasons for that. One was, the preacher was the most independent leader in the community.
He was accountable to the congregation, not to the Chamber of Commerce. And so therefore he could withstand oppression from the white community,
economic oppressions, otherwise better than to somebody else. And secondly, the example of Jesus, the teachings, particularly on the New Testament, led us to nonviolence.
Jesus, on the cross, asked his father to forgive those who had nailed him to the cross. And that spirit of nonviolence, and non retaliation, and non hatred of those who had hated you was the thing that we had said through.
But theologically, we were committed to law and love your enemy. And the New Testament says, and bless those who persecute you.
And we discovered that it was not only effective, it was outwardly, but it was effectively inwardly for us.
We became new creatures because we pursued that theology. And we actually avoided hating. I never forget two or three times I met with George Wallace, that he remarked he was astounded by the fact that our spirit was nonviolence.
So we were never done and reflected love, or if you couldn't quite make love, we did not reflect hatred in our attitude toward, toward, even those who persecuted us.
And it was a strange weapon for white ruffians, and even the citizens' counsel, who were the respectable, you know, group among the two. But they couldn't understand it. And they tried to call it cowardice, which you couldn't call cowardice.
And the people who would walk into the face of fire and into the face of the beast, unarmed and singing, go to Gloria, Hallelujah.
And that was the power of the movement. It touched people's hearts everywhere. I remember white ladies saying to me once in Nashville that she was opposed to the direct action movement. She thought it was stirring up trouble.
But once she watched how we conducted ourselves and how our process conducted themselves, she's in no comparison. The spirit of the Lord is upon you. And I'm opposed to what they are doing.
And it was a long, she's come a long, long way because at first she was opposed to she wanted everything to be settled through the law. But you know, we never did. We never did get a clear judicial interpretation of the city.
And I don't think even to this day we have a clear cut opinion from the Supreme Court about cities. But of course the outlaw of segregation in public accommodations, the Congress didn't so far.
So it became a move question. But but the power of the movement, both in terms of touching those who opposed the preceptus. And in terms of our own spiritual behavior and our spiritual strengthening, it was a great experience for us.
And also ask you 59, John's going to switch tracks. We're back on after a quick break. Let me ask obviously in through the late 50s, you and others were targeted in a libel campaign to men to obviously harass and not give back a notch. And it didn't have its effect.
I mean, ultimately the Supreme Court would reach its decision. But that was years down the line. Can you talk about the personal ramifications of say the property seizures and others in 59 for you?
You right talk to my children who some of them can remember when the officers came took our car when they got the judgment. All they could find was my automobile. I was living in the church postage.
So they couldn't attach my house. And so there was the only thing clearly in my name was was the automobile. Now I can say it now. But I lived in Moebe with my home once in Huntsville. And I had inherited my sister and I some property from my father.
And so we told our attorney for God's sake don't don't mention Huntsville because we don't want them to be awakened to possibly they might take our property in Huntsville as they did Abernathy took farmland from Abernathy.
So the lawyers agreed they did not mention Huntsville. So when I got on the stand in Montgomery. They first asked me, "Where do you live? I said 306 North Warren, Moebe. And where were you born? And I almost fainted because we had already agreed with the lawyer for God.
He was following his routine questioning. And I guess my answer should have been Huntsville but the Lord spoke to me and my answer was Madison because Huntsville was in Madison County. And there was a little town in Madison County named Madison.
But I didn't say I just said Madison. And so they never discovered the property that we had at which they would have seized as they did Abernathy in Marengo County because they found out about his land.
But that was an interesting suit when we are when it was augured before the Supreme Court. One of the justices was Jewish. And the little lawyer, (M.) Roland Nachman who was representing the city of Montgomery.
And the New York Times was sued along with the four of us - Abernathy, Shuttlesworth, Seay, and myself. The New York Times would not let us be covered under their bond.
They may know what they call a supersedeas bond. And I'm a little reluctant to buy the New York Times at the IULU and read somebody else's. But they would not let us be protected under their bond. And the reason was that if they did, it would give them some stake in Alabama citizenship when they can be subject to persecution by the Alabama citizenship.
And by the Alabama authorities, if they had any reason to be claimed to claim Alabama, they claimed they didn't belong [to. The Alabama authorities had no power to attach them. But it didn't help us any. It took off property.
And of course, the Supreme Court later reversed the law courts. And in an argument before the Supreme Court, I was about to say what this lawyer named (M.) Roland Nachman was asked by Justice.
Justice said, you demanded that the defendant produce that property. And you kept, Sammy Davis was just married. I think her name was May Britt.
And the white folks in Alabama were very displeased with that. And Sammy Davis was on the list of citizens that posted the ad that gave them the right to sue in the first place. And when (M.) Roland Nachman was making his summer to the jury, he said, you ministers were sitting there with an A.R. of engine innocence.
You were proud to be on stand with Reinhold Niebuhr and Sammy Davis was Jr. and with Harry Belafonte and Sammy Davis was Jr. They called Sammy Davis was named the name because that reminded the jurors that Sammy Davis had just married Blue Eyed Blonde. And that was very, very unpleasant for the Alabama jurors.
And so they didn't stay out very long. They went out and came back almost immediately found us guilty and took our property. But the Supreme Court later, of course, vindicated, overruled the law court.
And when they sold Abernathy's car and Shuttlesworth's car and say they all got new cars, but my members were more stooped.
The Methodist boys, they were down to the when they auctioned my car off and were real. My members went down and bid. They bid. I think they bought it for $8900. And then they brought it and gave it to my wife. The fellow who did the bidding was the fellow named Dewitt, R.B. Dewitt, who was Secretary of the YMCA, which was right across the street from our pauses.
And he bought it and brought it back and drove it into the yard and gave my wife the key. And she gave my dollar. And of course, the community raised $8900 and gave it back to Dewitt that he paid for the car.
But I'm the only one who didn't get a new car. It was those smart, astute Methodist who were down and bid for the same car and save money. But the Baptists let them take the car and they bought Abernathy and Shuttlesworth and say new cars.
I drove by the same old car on that, but that was a historic case in Lable.
What was the cost for just money? When the Supreme Court said it reversed it. What happened with the property? Did you get the property back?
He never took anything. The Supreme Court returned everything. They had to turn back everything. They turned back the money we got for that they got sale of the car. They had to give it back to us. And we gave it back to the organization which had furnished the money.
And the first phase, three embers the man who was paid it.
Let's pause just one quick step.
Ever in the hour, you mentioned a few moments ago that obviously when the students get involved in 1960 and the dam sort of breaks with the direct action sit in movement,
the tenor of the movement shifts pretty quickly forward. And I'm really interested in your perspective on that period between early 1960, the Greensboro sit in, say.
And that that's several years through the early sit-in phase, freedom rise of 61 Albany, Southwest Georgia, 62.
And then the eve of Birmingham in 63 when SCLC will really now take a first step that will really shift SCLC onto the national stage in a very, very dramatic way.
Well, the movement was was evolutionary, although it's seen revolutionary at the time. But things changed considerably.
And it became a worldwide movement. And it not only dealt with voter registration and public transportation as it did in the beginning with buses,
but it had to do with segregation as a whole. And public accommodations were significant.
The court did rule clearly on public accommodations. And in 64, the court's immediate very clear that that segregation and public combination was unconstitutional.
And that was a tremendous movement. I remember I was in Nashville in time, maybe in 63 or first of 64, for God's sake.
And we were demonstrating at various restaurants and we were demonstrating in Morrison's, which is out of business now.
Now, I think they were bought out by Piccadilly. Where do you live?
In the Piccadilly.
And I don't know what we had.
But there were Morrison's in North Carolina. But anyway, they, they, they, they, they, they, they feller who owned Morrison's, I forgot.
And I think they were based in Mobile. And I was living in Nashville. I went to the governor of Tennessee and asked him to ask the president of Morrison's to desaturate.
And we could stop the demonstrations. And he called the head of Morrison's. And I was sitting in his office.
And he told the head of the mayor of Morrison's. And I will never owe him my dead body.
And the civil rights act took effect, I think, in June of 64. And Morrison's was desaturated in July.
And the president died a month later. So he was true to his word. He said he would be over his dead body.
And we, black what he didn't notice. He went on and died. I don't think he planned it that way. But that's the way it happened.
But by that time the issue was universally recognized as a new era.
And it was, I think the new era began in Montgomery with the boycott. The Montgomery boycott was the first boycott of an entire community that worked.
And that was what I call the beginning of the era of self-determination. It didn't matter what the court said.
No, what the legislature said. We were through with the back of the bus. And blacks took responsibility for their feet in their own hands.
And decided we weren't going to ride the bus as long as they were safe again.
I think that was the era of self-determination. And later the sick and sit-ins was another expression of self-determination.
When we decided we weren't going to permit them to sell us toothpaste and safety pins. On one account we had to go to a black account to eat lunch at Woolworths.
And I got an award from the people in Greenborough, North Carolina some years ago. People who were responsible for the sit-ins in North Carolina, which was another expression of self-determination.
That they say what you want to coach without eating at the black lunch counter. And so eventually they disappeared.
So that's just the last couple of questions. I'm very generous with your time and I want to not keep it too long.
No, I like you. I like to rate you pay.
Let me ask about, when you think about the spring of 65 and Selma.
I'd like for you to describe what comes to your mind when you think about that, that all of Selma and all of that March.
And in particular I'm very interested in how you yourself confronted and dealt with all of the fear associated with facing that kind of situation.
It wasn't new to you by then, but nonetheless it was acute.
Well, it's interesting, as I said to you earlier, that the spirit of nonviolent not only had an impact on the oppressors, but it had a spirit of impact on us.
And we became new creatures. We did not hate Bull Connor.
We did not hate the man who killed Dr. King, James Earl Ray. We never, we wanted them not to to spare his life.
We did not to execute him. It had a spiritual impact on us.
And the Selma movement was an interesting movement in that it was after the Birmingham movement that we went to the A.G. Gaston Motel in Birmingham and held a retreat and decided that we were going to Selma to conduct a campaign to get the vote.
Because we went to President (Lyndon B.) Johnson and said we came out. He said, well, we got a slow down for us and said we just passed the Civil Rights Act of 1964.
We can't have another civil rights act this quickly. Y'all take it easy. So we left went to Birmingham, met in A.G. Gaston Motel and planned to sell the movement.
Picked Selma because I think SNCC may have been already there, but they had been abused and persecuted terribly. They weren't even forbidden to hold meetings.
And also the black belt of Alabama was a natural place because it was so black.
They said it was black because of dirt. But I think they called it black because of so many black folk who are majority populations.
And Dallas County where Selma was located was majority black and didn't have but a handful of black registered voters in 1964 and 65.
And so the movement was begun in Selma. And the march from Selma to Montgomery, which was the climax of that movement, began after Jimmie Lee Jackson was killed, who was killed in Marion, Alabama.
And my wife has a project on the SCO's, the women which she had, she has put statues and memorials of people like James Reeb and Jimmie Lee Jackson and others who died.
Simulti Jackson was the first death in the movement. And we determined to get the right to vote. And after we had Jimmie Lee Jackson's funeral, we were marching to his grave.
That's when somebody suggested we order march to Montgomery. The state capital demanded the right to vote. And we did. And that Bloody Sunday. They didn't get any further than the bridge. But that next few days we did go on across that bridge.
And in the next few days, we let out for Selma for Montgomery. And it reached Montgomery and you know the rest of history after the mass meeting in Montgomery that day when Martin spoke how long, not long.
And he named a committee to take the demands of the march to go to Governor (George) Wallace. And he named me, Chairman of the committee. And Mr. Wallace had said he wasn't going to meet with anybody who wasn't from Alabama.
And so I was passing in Birmingham. So he named me, (likely) L.H. (Luther) Foster - Tuskegee president ever been in the President of Tuskegee. Several outstanding citizens of Alabama to meet with Governor (George) Wallace to discuss the demands of the march.
And so I had the demands at the close of the mass meeting. And I went to the general who headed the National Guard and said, I want to take these demands up to the Capitol.
So he got on the telephone. I assume he was talking with the governor. And finally said, go ahead, you can go. But when we got to the steps to the Capitol, the troopers, what I call the blue sea, they had already blew uniform. They lined the steps of the Capitol and would not let us through.
And I know who that Moses felt when he faced the blue sea. He was a red sea. He faced, but I faced the blue sea. We couldn't get through. So I looked back at the general.
And I said, you know, pointed to the troopers and I thought you said we could go. And he yelled out some military command. And then I went, up, up.
And the National Guard came from around the corner and they stood in front of the troopers. And they put their bare nets across the shelters. And the blue sea parted. Just like the red sea.
They parted and we walked through and went up to the governor's office. We got to the door of the Capitol. The governor said in the secretary to say he would take the petition.
We walked 50 miles. We're not about to give it to the secretary. So I refused to give it to him. And about four or five days later, they had governor called and said he would meet with certain members of the committee.
And he picked out some. I was not one of the chairman was not one that he picked to meet with. But the I pulled the committee, the committee voted the analysis. It was all or nothing at all.
So the next day he called and said he'd meet with us. So he did. He met with us for about 90 minutes. And while we're meeting the governor, governor had a little piece of paper, a tub of piece of paper. And by the time he finished with a big mountain, a little scraps of paper. He had torn up while we were meeting. And I told him that the guard was going to hold him accountable for how he stood in the way of people.
Making progress and coming together as children of God. But that and of course, pretty soon we had the voting rights act or 65, which probably the most significant piece of legislation in our lifetime.
Because it changed the whole voting pattern of the nation. And the fellow we have in the White House today would not be there. Had it not been for the voting rights act of 1965.
That's my last question. Just to have you reflect a little bit on of course you gave the benediction in BC. I was there that day. I heard you live in person. It was very pleased for that opportunity. Just just your reflections on on how that long arc from from
the real and Birmingham and Montgomery all the way to Washington. Well, you know, we're talking the other day. And I noticed doing first time doing the Freedom Riders film. I heard Bobby Kennedy say that there's going to be a black president one day. Now somebody says he said 40 years.
I didn't hear the 40 years, but I did hear him say there'd be a black president. We all felt one day. There'd be a black president. But none of us thought we'd live to see it. And just the way things were at that time we just couldn't foresee a black president.
And here in 19, in 19, when you said we had the anyway, we went when when Barack Obama decided to run.
And it's something happened to me. Spiritsly. And I became one of his early supporters when hardly any other civil rights leaders were supporting him. I was out there supporting him. And I just felt like God was moving in history. And the time had come. And I wasn't sure he could be elected, but I thought the time had come for him to run.
But unlike Jesse Jackson's (1984's campaign, which was purely symbolic, none of us ever, you know, nobody ever thought Jesse Jackson's (1984 was going to win. But it was a symbolic run. It was a good thing. But Barack Obama's campaign took on a different view. And it appears that he might have a chance to win.
I went all over the country and went to sell them in my side. What was that?
2007, I think. Brown Chapel AME. Yeah, Brown Chapel AME. Apple 2007. And I was supposed to speak at first Baptist church. I had spoken in Brown Chapel AME, Apple here before. And Barack Obama was going to speak in Brown Chapel AME. Apple.
When I got to first Baptist, I heard of Obama was supposed to speak at Brown Chapel AME, Apple. I got a headache. And I said, I can't. I'm going to send you some of us. So we sent somebody. And I went to Brown Chapel AME, Apple. See here. Barack Obama. And he made an interesting speech.
I said in my argument, they call on me to make a mark before he spoke. I hadn't counted on that. But I said that I talked about good crazy. There's good crazy and bad crazy.
YouTube picked it up and people were seeing it all over the country. But I said that I was going to go on over to Brown Chapel AME, Apple, to meet with the crazy people who talked about a black president. And I said, people are saying, you're crazy. But that's good crazy. And that's bad crazy. And good crazy.
You know, is on the right side and the right side of history. And he spoke that day. And he said that he represented the Joshua generation. He looked back at me and John Lewis. And he said, you got represent Moses generation. I thought that was a sneaky way to call us. Oh, you know, but he was right. And he said, he represented Joshua generation. And something happened in me.
That this guy is inspired. And I think God is moving. And I decided at that time that I would support him. And I march across the bridge with him that day. My wife and I together. And then later he came to Atlanta and spoke on a Georgia Tech campus.
And he asked me to come out and pray it that day. And maybe that's why he got the idea. I might want to pray at the Nova racing. But that was a Georgia Tech. And my about 2025,000 students and people out there. And I went all over the country. He asked me, call me once after he fired up Jackson, speak for him.
He couldn't keep it. He and Hillary were supposed to speak. And this daughter here, Cheryl, said she was going with me. They were going to send a plane. And I don't think she knew they were going to send a little small plane because I didn't know.
I'm not sure I would have agreed to go if I had known there was sending such a small plane. But anyway, he said this is a small plane. And we flew over there. And I spoke that night. And I went all over the country speaking of North Carolina, Virginia, Alabama. Georgia.
And I was, as a matter of fact, after Georgia Tech, I went to Iowa. I wanted to see if the White folks were serious. Whether they said they support, I wasn't sure. I know he couldn't win without getting white support.
And I went up there, it was getting chilly. And I saw people standing on the corner with red noses and red ears. And little sign that said, yes, we can. And I said, God is in this plan. And I went all over the country speaking for him. And he won.
And most of my friends, Andy Young and John Lewis, they supported Hillary. They couldn't see it. But I told him, when we were calling, they weren't living close enough to the Lord.
But we felt it was God inspired plan. And sure enough, he was elected. And when he called me, he called me on my cell phone. And I wasn't there. He left a message. And when I got the message, he asked me to call him.
And I called him back. And I said, I want to speak to the fellow who's going to be in the 44th president of the United States. And he said, that would be me, with Larry. As you call it, yes, I called you. I want to ask you if you would give the benediction or the invocation at the inauguration.
And I said, well, let me check my, let me check my calendar. And quickly, I said, I'm checking. I'm free. I'm glad to do it. Glad to do it. He said, but we'll call you when he called me. Well, if I could appear to paper before he called, that I was to do the benediction.
And so my friends called us and, oh, we're going to protest. We want you to do the invocation. No, no, no. I'll take the benediction. And I have the last word at the inauguration with the benediction. And of course, it wasn't.
People told me in Washington, he said, when you stand on the steeps of the White House, you'll be able to see the Washington monument and the Lincoln Memorial from that looking down that mall. And I look forward to it. And I, I could see a little of it, but there was a slight haze that day. And these old eyes were there about 80.
I said, maybe 80 years old at the time. And they, they failed. I couldn't see both the monument and the Lincoln Memorial, but I didn't have to see it because I heard that day.
From the next episode, liquor, more, I heard the voice of Martin Luther King 40 some years earlier, summoning a nation to come up out of the low land of race and color to the higher ground of content of character.
And here I was witnessing and participating in the nation's response to that summons in the election of Barack Obama. And I think it was God's plan, God's intent. And I think the will of God was fulfilled. And America, I never liked the National Anthem.
I always thought it was a poor choice for, bombs bursting in air and so forth. But that day when they played it after I gave him an addiction, he sounded better than it ever sounded before.
And nothing had changed, but the Star-Spangled Banner was the same, but the country had changed. And I was overwhelmed. And I cried. I need to say I did, I did, grown man. And his coldness was the wonder of tears, the one icicles, it's cold that day.
But the Star-Spangled Banner sounded good that day as it played when they inaugurated the 44th president of the United States.
We're just so grateful for this chance. Thank you so much for coming for the church today and sitting down with us.
You were sending contributions to post office box. What's the, what's the institute post office box? 108 97. What is it? What is it, Tara?
Yeah, post office box 9 2801 Joseph Lowery Institute. We'll be glad to receive contributions from the Smithsonian. And from all of its affluent staff representatives who fly around the country with cameras taking statements.
I think those would be fun as well spent. Thank you very much. It's a real pleasure. I'm glad to have been, I'm sorry I was late. It slipped. I don't know what it slipped. Thank you so much.
It slipped me, you're still here. I want to call you. You can take me back. Okay. They brought me over.
This has been a presentation of the Library of Congress and the Smithsonian National Museum of African American History and Culture.